alright I'm back I was about to go to
sleep and as I was I don't say as I was
drifting off but yeah I was very much
ready to sleep and then I see Magnus
starts playing a match online against
Andrew tang so we're gonna watch some
very high level bullets Magnus
playing under dr. Nick Turse Dean and
Andrew tang playing as penguin GM this
is where Andrew is very strong and like
these time scramble situations and I
mean he might actually win this as white
okay it's the draw fair results
objectively drawn Rick ending so they
started playing just like five minutes
ago so I'm catching the beginning of a
match who knows how long this is going
to to be there are there's currently
over 550 spectators watching on me chess
and the current match score at least for
today is three and a half to one and a
half lifetime Magnus has a pretty
substantial lead
and usually when they play these types
of matches I mean there's at least like
20 to 30 games if not more though Magnus
had a match against this Iranian GM
Faraj a few weeks ago and they played I
think over 70 games it's crazy
hey we have people in the chats Belgian
novice row managers I was not planning
to stream but Carlson's playing so and
and neither Carlsen nor penguin are
streaming so I figured why not offer
some commentary I don't know how useful
my commentary will be what's the pollen
counts Oh penguins up a pond but Magnus
has rook activity yeah these rooks are
monsters
but this pawn is a future Queen
potential Queen and whites threatening
like some meeting ideas what's going on
the combination of two rooks and the
Knights are very tricky like that's
mates ouch oh man yeah just too much
coordination blacks rooks were out of
play there I don't believe either player
is live on Twitch but if anyone wants to
correct me that would be nice there is a
title arena where Magnus was live on
periscope but there was someone else
like in the same room as him streaming
from periscope no one really knew until
after the the thing was done
so yeah hello to everyone I would read
off names but I'm too tired to pronounce
names Carlson is okay he's broken 3000
Isle penguin was over 3,000 within the
last month but he took a dip maybe
partly and thanks to me I know I beat
him a couple of times this month
okay so black should be better here I
mean outside passer past plans must be
pushed whoa he's sacking a queen
what Wow but he's getting to this is
actually really interesting he is too
connected passers with the rook
potentially supporting play a - yeah
okay
oh but yeah that was a good decision by
White's because now it's the Queen for
two rooks or queen and two pawns for two
rooks but rook okay that rooks gonna
swing in or not
yeah Bishop a3 was questionable Wow so
penguin won a game and Magnus was back
below 3000 so it's two and a half to
four and a half is three thousand twelve
a record I'm pretty sure Magnus has
broken like 20 or let's say 20 no 3200
let me open his profile and a new tab
though it may have been under another
accounts why is white up a queen I
blinked for a moment and whites up a
queen
what's okay I guess people if they want
they can look at like that game you know
what happened there
3196 is a record according to Danny's
okay I'm checking Magnus's profile we go
to his bowler bathing better than a
hundred percent of players obviously Oh
highest rating okay so 31 41 but that's
not including dr. drew Rankin's Dean if
I spelled that correctly oh that's not
the right Oh cuz I need an Ian
drunk and steamed there we go
Oh highest rating hmm so I all know
which account has the highest rating I
would think it's Magnus though based on
these two accounts that looks like 31 41
is a record which will be hard to beat
because Magnus would need like a massive
winning streak at least in this match to
like even break 30 50 could I crush him
I mean I have a perfect score against
Magnus as far as I know so I've only
played them once and he was playing on
mobile I was actually challenging him
earlier hoping that he might
accidentally accept but then I saw he
started this match so now we're here
so Magnus is in a worse position like
Andrew should win this up nights time
scramble it's gonna be hard for a bhakta
cream move because the night's so tricky
and it's just a winning position - yeah
okay so the mat or the match get so
slightly closer three and a half to five
and a half I don't think Magnus has ever
done puzzle rush if he did he would have
a chance I would think at breaking
NACA's all-time high score of 55 I mean
I would assume he would be pretty good
and Fabiano has done pulser rush but
Fabiano score I don't think is that
impressive
yeah I don't think he makes the top 10
all time of course puzzle rush sometimes
comes down to if you have like one good
showing
but you have to be very very sharp with
tactics obviously this looks pretty good
for whites like bullet is all about
initiative Queen eight shades queen h8
will come probably at some points maybe
not it looks like it just wins material
okay he got the job done yeah I think
Magnus just stopped playing on the love
man with a van account after some
undesirable games but this has been his
main account for at least like the last
month or two I believe and penguin
streams a lot you can't just say why
doesn't penguin stream anymore he
streams like almost every week and he
was asked in one of his recent streams
if streaming affects his level of play I
think he said something like sometimes
it does but sometimes it hasn't knew it
no effect
oh he stream yesterday okay yeah there
was like some bullet tournament
yesterday I think okay so if we count
the pawns penguins up upon but down on
time opposite Clark bishops Magnus wins
a pawn back but this G pawn is a little
bit tender probably gonna see they're
coming at some points go for work h7
which rooks are more active
okay these works are clearly more active
more coordinated to Magnus is so good at
these types of positions he's still good
at any type of position but any sort of
endgame if it's equal
okay so now blocks up a pond I guess he
didn't take his Bishop c4 could have
been a problem my bishop is so slippery
all right so we're going to see another
time scramble penguin has five seconds
but okay three two three I mean black is
winning but will he have enough time to
convert I think yeah penguins just too
fast
I'll give Magnus on the verge of winning
but just too slow whoa that's a small
notification we have our first sub of
the stream you move this up
thanks for the sub Raya appreciate it
was this a scandi this is a scandi right
oh no this is a French Oh some weird
exchange French looks like a scandi okay
let's catch up current position looks
comfortable for black looks very
comfortable this is a fork knight black
can win the rook always repeats
sometimes these bullet matches are all
about momentum like if you can string a
few mins together it can be demoralizing
and tilting and tilting and demoralizing
are basically the same thing
f4 is hanging oh no it's not because it
might spins
well now the Knights pinned he should
have taken on that four I think
wait but okay blocks of exchange ah from
earlier another sub dice 99 3-1 thanks
for subbing do I think any of the old
masters before computers would be more
dominant than Magnus if they were in
their prime today that's a hard question
to answer if they were in their prime
oh but would they have access to
computers because I think computers just
have changed the game like modern
players are just so much better than
players of the past I would think at
least in terms of opening theory which
is a huge component of the game okay we
have another time scramble again Magnus
is better but he's gonna flag and now
he's worse penguin is just too fast the
mouse speed it's so important in bullets
he's strong but he's just too slow so
it's not enough so some benoni free
bishop was that Bishop g5
so blocks of the piece but penguins not
resigning going for blood what is this
he 5f5 can you play six just gain more
space because II six allows 9 f 6
reminds me of a Halloween gambit where
the pawns are just in your face the
black is up a piece oh it's a skewer
Magnus is good at tactics resigned no
resign Brooke b3 or just win when one of
the pawns
yeah e5 pawn just yeah White's pieces
are vanishing I'm not sure why Penguins
not resigning here but he does like to
fight
Queen a7 coming yeah see some brutal
meats okay what just happened of new
game
hey it's a London but it's some London
Queen's Gambit hybrid okay play is
unfolding very quickly so my QP position
these are very pleasant positions for
bullets because what just has a long
term kind of nagging edge pawn got
traded now White's just ahead and
development this Bishop is sometimes
just annoying to develop these pieces
are so nice all of whites pieces so nice
I mean defend the pond or beads or b6
now Angie's down 20 seconds why is he
thinking for so long oh it's a tactic
but white just gots a lot of material
for the Queen
yeah this is still much better for
whites like there's some mating ideas
maybe here in Bishop f7 I can't draw
arrows quickly enough that was nice
f3 mates tell that to Ben Feingold
another London I'm liking what I see so
this is a common way for black to play
against in London these days exchange
caro-kann wear black that's kind of a
preferable move order hey it's another
sub-collector oh it's been a while since
I've seen you live I honestly don't
remember that name but thanks for
something I appreciate it Wow Daniel is
solid and extremely resourceful who's
Daniel do you mean you mean penguin and
rooting so so many London's this is so
great to see Bishop g3 he's gonna play
Bishop e5
this is his line I learned it from him
Bishop d3 neither 5s an improvement the
very first video in my London course I
go over this there's a very nice Carlson
game where he plays Bishop b5 his wins
essentially with opening preparation
so this position again it's nice
positioning that h5 was a threat to win
the Queen not h5 still played Wow
some Knights got traded it's nice to
play against this pawn because White has
full control of her d4 and Carlson is
about to do Carlsen things and just like
maneuver around keep applying pressure a
king f2 at some points should have
played king f2 he just lost a pawn for
no reason but he's probably gonna win
this pawn like c4 a good move because it
takes under Knight takes hey another sub
Henry Lord what what on or is it
watching thanks for subbing this is it
strange the the thing appeared twice in
the chat I don't know if that's a bug
huh what is this ending is white winning
White's winning he's this is known as a
crippled majority Carlsen just one is
this a twitch bug or did like did you
actually sub twice because there's said
I have the notification twice here I
think you just subbed once thank you
though maybe I'll play around someday
with keeping the chats on the whole
stream but sometimes it just distracts
from though what the tension should be
focused on what does this opening Lizer
know each pawn
ok
what an opening what is this is this
opening takes on G two triple pawns on
the C file whoa it's gifted subs by
terrible chess or terrible at chess and
then there's another sub rengar ax oh my
gosh this is overwhelming I don't know
whether to look at the new subs or still
focus on this game because whites up
upon somehow the opening worked outs are
the middle game work downs like I'll
look away for a second and then the
position completely changes thank you so
much terrible at chess and welcome to
all the new subs wait so materials equal
again are they gonna repeat King b3 go
back and forth just yeah just as a draw
King a3 so White's playing for a win but
black has a future Queen white also has
a future Queen
how do you play c2 I don't think he can
play c2 so the palms get traded and
blacks just down a pawn
so Andrews playing for a win but he has
to last seconds but he's ridiculously
fast I don't know who I would put money
on probably whites
yeah White's gonna win cuz he's so fast
even though he's still down 2 seconds
now he's only down one second and now
time is about what is going on it's a
pawn race but he's gonna start checking
Queenie five trade Queens he flagged Wow
Karlsson flagging and rooting in a time
scramble you'll see that too often
I was so depressing because like the
final move just King takes Queen let me
read off these some names because we
have a somewhat boring opening
by the time I read off the names this
game will probably be over so the new
subs ring Gaara lere lere gova dom a
play to play to play deathly claw ow
stamms have 84 [ __ ] dome a [ __ ] costs
Satomi whatever your name is
numero Tom drug Jack running and is you
wrong QL terrible a chest deserves a
thank you I'm sorry you're so terrible
at chess
you're not terrible at gifting subs okay
so what does this position whites just
so active b7 is attacked three times now
we'll probably see Brooke b7 and maybe
Queen d7 mate or just take a free pawn
but black actually has stuff defended
this is a very strange position like
there is no mates this King is
completely naked on c8 but the Queen
actually does a good job at defending
rook takes f4 there's gathered even some
meat here where's the mates Queen g8
Queen g8 King takes rook there maybe the
King runs away Magnus is gonna flag
because he spent all that time looking
for meat which maybe just wasn't there
and now his king is naked
he's one second left and then Gees just
meeting what a game that game deserves
further analysis because that there had
to be a win there somewhere for whites
okay so this is some sort of interesting
line a five is actually a very romantic
idea for the slime I played this a few
times similar stuff a while ago and
white has a bishop parrot but black has
some nice pieces this knight on d4 so
strong so the current score is 11 and a
half to six and a half not a bad
performance by Andrew Carlsen still
trying to get back over 3,000 Queen g2
coming my blocks just crushing here
material blocks also up a pawn not that
it matters the ship t4 nice there's all
the black pieces they're all like
pointing towards the king this is brutal
I was really brutal another London I'm
so happy this is such happiness we're
gonna see the Bishop b5 line again there
should be five yes
now each six was h6
yeah it looks like Andrew equalized like
really no clear advantage her life black
might even be better here
I played 97 unleash the C file but if my
t7 isn't played soon oh it's all about
the Knights on c5 if I can effectively
reinforce it then White's better but if
not black shouldn't be better yeah it's
funny but like the the theory and in
these bullet Kings are like it'll be
interesting to analyze afterwards
especially for a London player this is
not every day you get Carlsen playing so
many games in a specific opening
especially the London even if it's one
minute be interesting to like see the
nuances
so material is actually still equal but
I'm liking black like the center is nice
this bishop there should be some tactics
96 was not the most impressive discovery
maybe I have to like White's takes wait
takes takes takes that would just be a
trade but yet again okay we're gonna see
another time scramble and you're having
far less time but not by much
okay four seconds per player three
seconds per player yeah this is all out
just mud throwing Carlson is gonna flag
yep
couldn't even finish my sentence penguin
is too fast yeah there should be there
should be a chestful book basically
Magnus's bullet games why is the king on
my face again I blinked for a moment was
it a massive Oh Queen h5 that's
interested in Queen h5 Queen d1 so white
looks better here I mean this King looks
very shaky more structure for black good
center control for whites
Knight f4 and at some point maybe g3 ooh
that was I don't even know what's going
on yeah neither four there we go
Knights are so confusing sometimes
okay Queens attacked maybe the Queen
could sneak in like taking Queen a seven
you know you want to do it yes and then
you can start munching on pawns while
you got maded on the kingside but is
there any mate maybe Knight g3 Queen f6
controlled
yeah I would rather be black here but
it's tricky both Kings are a bit exposed
a queen bee six-pack G for Wow
but now the G pawns pinned Bishop d7 was
useful this King is finding shelter kind
of the Queen still being annoying but
okay huge time advantage and material
advantage for black should be easy win
now this is too strong did he disconnect
he disconnected you left the game I
think that's it that's not even a
ragequit because he won maybe it's a
happy quit and there's over 600
spectators in this game well both
players offline now what is this it
ended so abruptly they play in it
I do math they played 21 games 13 and a
half to 7 and a half
Magnus finishes below 3000 but not too
far away from 3000 well that was fun
I was not planning to stream more
tonight but I felt like doing commentary
for this so yeah maybe they were well
andrew is i think andrew is playing the
protesting in a few hours and I'll be
doing commentary for a protest League in
7 hours so I think I'll end it there
I'll probably upload this to YouTube so
for the YouTube audience and for the
twitch audience I'll see you guys in the
future